several years back I visited the Warner
Brothers animation studios the renowned
Warner Brothers animation studios here
at the WB LA and I sat down with a
legendary animator Bruce Timm together
we cooked up on the spot improvised a
Conan superhero where Bruce Timm was
illustrating and I was just throwing out
a bunch of random stupid ideas check it
out
belt with things thing that holds my
blackberry on a style I see but maybe
with flames coming off and maybe there's
some steam coming off of it I'd like to
be the first guy that's wearing shoes
like loafers how about sauce like an old
man's socks with garters business and
garters and socks yes this is remarkable
look at that
well
doesn't get better than that anyway I'm
excited to announce that next week at
Comic Con we're gonna be debuting three
episodes it is the not so distant future
in a world of madman monsters and
talking toilets I await your experiment
only one man can protect us
sorry grumps what is urban Mittal fury
is in turn Rachael and Randy the world's
most powerful computer beep boop boo the
prophecy must search the multiverse for
three fragments of the president's
consciousness theory
okay it does sound fun but it's not
coming to Comicon this July hey let's go
me at the flaming see Andy is the bad
guy ellie kemper as the flaming sees
intern Jon Glaser as the president of
Earth Steven Wright as the world's most
powerful computer it's a lot of fun
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please